hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear so
in terms of horror movies in general uh
i feel like the 1980s yes there was a
lot of different uh genres going on but
i feel like the 1980s was kind of like
the decade of the slasher right i mean
they were very easy to make for a low
budget kind of like you know found
footage or zombie ones would be later on
um at the time there was a huge booming
video market and the movies could go
direct to video
and you know back then there wasn't a
lot to do like other than go rent movies
so they had this built-in audience of
horror fans who would rent pretty much
anything that had like a cool premise a
cool cover and had maybe some creative
or grizzly kills in it or nudity boobies
whatever like you know so you had like a
ready-made audience there already for
you
by the time the latter part of the 80s
rolled around though i feel like
slashers were kind of like on a little
bit of a decline at least in the u.s um
i guess that there were some european
filmmakers that were still kind of
cranking them out for the american video
market
so one of these movies which
not exactly lost in the sense of being
like completely forgotten about but it
did go direct to vhs back in 1988
and sort of then after that like slipped
under the radar a little bit
but it has been i guess rediscovered if
you want to use that term and it has
been given a recent uh really nice
restoration and blu-ray release from i
believe arrow video who always do
amazing work and the movie that we are
referring to is actually the
spanish-american co-production known as
edge of the axe
now this is a very
oddball kind of slasher
it was directed by jose ramon laraz
using the pseudonym joseph bronstein for
this
he's probably best known to horror fans
today for directing the 1974 like erotic
horror film vampires with the y
uh and the 1987
slasher film like rest in pieces both of
which i have seen at various times uh
his last horror film which i haven't
seen was released in 1990 it was also a
slasher film and it was titled deadly
manor
now i will admit that i had never
actually heard of edge of the axe until
shutter added it to their lineup a while
back i don't know if it's on shutter
anymore at least in the us but it is on
to be and various other streaming
services so you can absolutely like
watch it for free so i was actually kind
of intrigued to check it out i mean
slashers aren't my favorite sub genre of
horror that would probably be like
haunted house movies or maybe like
giallo um i guess slashers are kind of
like modified gela movies but because it
was kind of being touted as this
underseen gem i figured that i should
probably like give it a watch at some
point because it just kept turning up on
like all these streaming services just i
guess because arrow did like a big
pretty like re-release of it so while i
will say that in my personal opinion i
don't think that edge of the axe is a
particularly notable example of you know
the slasher form maybe but it does have
enough weird quirks to it to absolutely
make it worth watching um it's not
especially gory and there's no sex and
no nudity so don't go into it like
thinking that you're gonna get that but
the killer has kind of like a creepy
look it is a little bit michael myersy
but it has its own thing going on and
some of the axe kills and other special
effects are actually really decent and
i'm sure that they probably just used
like a rubber axe or whatever for this
but one thing that i will give this
credit for is that i kind of feel like
in a lot of other axe murder slasher
type movies like they kind of swing the
axe and they cut away and then you just
kind of see the aftermath whereas this
one actually does look like somebody's
actually hitting somebody repeatedly
like with an axe and it kind of really
does look like it's going into them so
you know and and i like the way that
they kind of like pulled that off it
just seems a lot more even though it's
not all that gory it seems a lot more
violent or it seems a lot more visceral
just because it looks kind of like more
realistic
um now the characters in this are i'm
gonna say uh largely unlikable and some
of them are downright obnoxious and uh
there are kind of too many red herrings
and like subplots and stuff like that
that don't really factor into the
overall story but i mean that aspect
gave me a little bit of a giallo vibe
because some you know some kind of
lesser gela movies have that as well so
i didn't really mind it all that much on
the other hand though i will say that
keeping track of all the characters and
like their relationships to one another
was kind of confusing like even for me
and i'm usually i'm a writer so i
usually try to keep track of all that
stuff and i was just like wait who is
this now and how are you related to who
is this i don't know what the [ __ ]
going on so um and i will say to you
that i was able to guess
the big twist ending without too much
trouble uh your mileage may vary on that
because i have seen like some other
reviews they said oh they didn't see it
coming i actually guessed it but i don't
know if that's necessarily because oh
i'm so big and smart and everything but
it's just i've seen like some other
movies like this and so i was kind of
like oh i see what you're doing there
yeah so i guessed it uh because and
there were like a lot of deliberate
obfuscation and false leads and stuff
like that but i knew what they were
doing and so i was able to kind of like
cut through all the stuff and be like
yeah i see which i know what you're
gonna do i know what you're gonna do and
yeah i was right
so the story of edge of the axe
it takes place in this kind of small
mountain town called paddock i think
it's called paddock and it's near big
bear lake in california now as far as i
could determine most or all of the
exteriors in this were actually shot on
location in big bear lake california uh
i think most of the interiors and some
of the other kind of like smaller pickup
shots and stuff like that were actually
shot in madrid spain like i said because
this is a spanish uh co-production
now at the very beginning of the movie
uh we see this woman sitting in her car
smoking and the car is going through the
car wash
and she gets not all that graphically
axed to death by a dude in a white mask
who very determinedly like walks
straight through all the swirling car
wash machinery [ __ ] uh to kind of
dispatch his victim so you know you
gotta give him points for determination
i guess uh so there's a close-up of like
a red medical cross sticker like on the
woman's car window like the driver's
side window which will actually
factor into the plot it will make some
sense later on so anyway now that we
know that there's an axe murder on the
loose as if the title of the movie
didn't clue you in already uh we kind of
get eased into the main story
so our lead character sort of i guess is
this young guy named gerald uh played by
an actor named barton falks who i think
was not i think he maybe he teaches
acting nowadays but he was only like in
a couple of movies
so this character gerald he arrived in
paddock a short time before for some
unclear reason i don't really think they
ever give any reason i don't know if
he's just like i don't know he's just
like wandering around from place to
place so he's been staying in this cabin
on the property of this cranky old coot
named brock i think is his name
now brock is always giving gerald [ __ ]
because all of gerald's computer
equipment because he's like a computer
nerd kind of and you know a pretty big
deal for 1988 i guess uh is kind of
apparently causing the cabins like
electric bill to just go through the
roof and brock is not having it now at
first like when i was first introducing
these characters i thought brock was
like gerald's grandpa or his uncle or
something because of the way they spoke
to one another it just seemed like
familial or like you know it just kind
of seemed like that but i guess not i
mean i guess that brock is just a random
old man that gerald rents a cabin from i
think i'm not entirely sure i thought
they were related because the way they
kind of like [ __ ] with each other seems
like i don't know like i said it seemed
like kind of familial and then at one
point uh gerald says i love you old man
and i'm just like okay but i don't know
i just thought it was weird i thought it
was his grandpa or his uncle but i guess
it's not and it doesn't really matter
like anyway but i'm just saying so
gerald's best friend is this kind of
budget tom cruise looking douche bag uh
named richard simmons yes that's really
his name uh and he's actually played by
paige mosley
who i thought looked kind of familiar
he's apparently like best known for
being on that 80s soap opera santa
barbara which i don't think i ever
watched that so i don't know if i would
have recognized him for that maybe my
grandma watched it or something like
that but i don't know he looked like
kind of familiar he does look kind of
tom cruisey though like he has that kind
of like cocky young tom cruise kind of
vibe going
so richard is an exterminator
and is also married to an older woman
named laura who's actually played by a
spanish actress named patty shepard and
basically like richard is basically
constantly banging on his wife i mean he
low-key threatens at one point to
quote-unquote fumigate her
and he openly admits to marrying her
only because she's rich so there's that
about five minutes into the movie i
think it's like literally five seven
minutes into the movie richard is
already like enthusiastically trying to
kick off an affair with this younger
woman who looks works at a tavern or
something or a restaurant or something
uh and i will also note too that gerald
the supposed good guy hero of the movie
uh is being his wingman in this even
though he's pretty i mean i'm pretty
sure that he knows that richard is
married because they talk about his wife
all the time so he's just like yeah go
get him tiger you know it was that kind
of thing so i was like okay that's a
little weird whatever so it turns out
that richard has been called out to this
tavern to investigate this terrible
smell that's coming from somewhere i
think in the basement
so he brings gerald along
for some reason i mean he says oh come
along with me because i need your nose
or he says something like that but
as we will soon see like the odor that
they're investigating is apparently so
overpowering that i'm not really sure
why you'd need like another person like
to sort of
triangulate where it was coming from i
don't know it was just like a whole
weird situation uh so unsurprisingly uh
you know because this is a slasher movie
the stink is coming from the dead body
of a former employee named maria
who has been stuffed up into the crawl
space like there's kind of like a you
know a
trapdoor type thing in the ceiling and
somebody stuffed her up there
uh incidentally i will say that i think
the corpse effect here was probably my
favorite of the whole movie like when
they pull the thing down like her body
comes down i think like that corpse
effect looks uh really good and i think
that was probably my favorite effect in
the movie so even though it's pretty
clear that this woman was most likely
murdered i mean she didn't stuff herself
up into a crawl space uh the local
sheriff
calls it a suicide and basically wants
to just kind of sweep everything under
the rug he doesn't want to like
investigate any crimes what the [ __ ] you
think this is a job or something like
that this is the same sheriff by the way
who and i can't remember if this happens
before or after this situation but uh he
very assholeishly like dismisses this
farmer who comes into his office to
report that somebody has been on his
farm has beheaded one of his pigs broken
into his house and then left the
decapitated pig's head like in the
middle of his bed and the sheriff
literally like he comes in a report says
he's like it scared my wife to death it
was somebody creeping around outside my
farm or whatever and the sheriff
literally tells him that this is a
direct quote call someone who gives a
[ __ ] and i was just kind of like really
wow um i was like um actually you're
paid to give a [ __ ] and it doesn't
really look like you're doing anything
particularly important at the moment so
maybe you should kind of you know get
off your ass and like do some [ __ ] yeah
so the the sheriff in this and i don't
know if this was like deliberate like
they were trying to be like funny or
something like that but the sheriff in
this is a real [ __ ] [ __ ] waffle i
mean he just basically tries to write
off because as the murders like start to
stack up like as the movie goes on and
he just wants to write off every single
one it's like with first one suicide it
was an accident she got hit by train or
some [ __ ] like that so i guess so he
doesn't have to like investigate
anything or like move an inch from his
desk chairs like oh we don't want to
panic everybody in the village i don't
have to do any work [ __ ] this [ __ ] so
it's that kind of thing uh i will say
too that both him and his deputies or
the other people working on the case are
also like super insensitive like about
the victims almost implying a couple
times and it's like ah they had it
coming or you know saying oh she looked
like hamburger you know what i mean i'm
just like great this is really the kind
of people you want like investigating so
there's that whole thing but like i said
i don't know if that was supposed to be
funny or if that was just i don't know
what it was it was just very very weird
so meanwhile while all that nonsense is
going on uh gerald has kind of like a
meet cute with this nice young girl
named lillian who's played by christina
marie lane and she's apparently the
daughter of a guy who owns another like
bar restaurant type establishment in
this little town
so gerald tries to impress lillian with
his vast knowledge of video games as
well as late 1980s computer technology
while also throwing a little
condescension into the mix there for oh
i don't think you'd understand this he
says
after he tells her something that's
really really easy to understand i'm
just kind of like okay that's how you
want to come at it blah so yeah so
apparently though
that's works she's charmed by his nerdy
but possibly dangerous drifter vibe
because like i said i'm not really sure
like why he moved there
and i know like in light of what comes
out later on like i know why they set it
up like that but yeah so uh yeah so the
two of them kind of start a little bit
of a romance
so gerald uh who has just set up a brand
new state of the art for 1988 a computer
system in his cabin
even offers to give lillian his old one
so that they can communicate with one
another on what i guess is like a very
instant like a very early like iteration
of maybe like instant messaging or
something or email or something like
that and it's weird because i mean i
give this movie credit it's one of the
few slashers that i can think of
actually maybe the only one that i could
think of uh that incorporates what was
then kind of advanced computer tech like
into the actual plot i guess you could
say the evil speak did that too or that
was more supernatural kind of thing but
the tech angle in this even features
some kind of pre-internet shenanigans
where gerald's computer can answer
questions that you ask it like you type
in questions like by accessing a central
terminal like he calls it that but it
predictably like lillian uses this
cutting edge feature to ask the computer
which is named icarus if gerald is gay
not really sure like why she because she
keeps going we'll turn around i'm going
to ask it something turn around i don't
want you to look and then he's like what
did you ask it it keeps saying like data
incomplete she's like i asked if you
were gay
this is like never brought up again i
was just like all right that's what i
mean like how it's very very oddball
this is like very oddball uh and another
thing like along those same lines i'll
note here too that some of the
conversations that people have with one
another especially the interactions
between these two between gerald and
lillian are really weird like not at all
like anything real life humans would
actually say to one another yeah it was
just giving me a real like oddball vibe
it's strange but it is actually kind of
entertaining to be honest because you
don't ever really know like what bizarre
turn of phrase is gonna fall out of the
character's mouth next so oh and i will
say too like the music in this is really
odd too it's mostly like these kind of
silly like upbeat country songs
one of the songs that they play a couple
times over the end credits and then they
played at one point earlier in the movie
too that actually has lyrics relating
directly to the murders but the song is
like real kind of like upbeat and
cheerful and it's just it's so bizarre
it's just it's kind of i mean this is
just like a kooky kind of flick you guys
so as the movie goes on uh more people
start falling prey to this roving axe
murderer including a beautician and
part-time prostitute named rita that's
one of the victims uh richard's older
wife laura who had actually recently
learned she was bankrupt so she got
murdered not too long after that so you
know she didn't have to live as a poor
person so i'm sure that was happy
that was a silver lining um laura's bit
on the side and possible early suspect
named christopher uh he gets killed too
he's actually played by jack taylor who
i immediately recognized from he was in
pieces from 1982 and he was also in the
ninth gate i think that's where i mostly
recognized it from uh the farmer's wife
uh from the earlier pig head incident
she gets murdered too
uh and the leader of the church choir i
guess she's like the leader there's her
no she doesn't play the organ i guess
she's like the the choir director or
something like that and it's a woman
named anna uh now her dog also gets it
sadly um although at least it happens
off-screen you do see like the dead dog
but they don't like show it getting axed
so there's that but yeah the dog gets
killed in this one too now along the way
uh you know while all these bodies are
piling up several people are also kind
of fleetingly hinted to be the killer
like i said there's a lot of red
herrings in this uh so some of these
include christopher who i mentioned
before i mean he's literally maybe in
one or two scenes before he gets killed
i don't even remember if he has any
lines
uh the town priest father clinton uh it
seems like they're trying to set him up
as a suspect for like five seconds like
because he acts sort of vaguely sketchy
in one scene but then the rest of the
time he's totally normal and the jack
wagon exterminator guy richard who
laughs about the axe murders and kind of
cracks oh i should talk to this axe
killer about getting rid of my wife
and i'm just like yeah well the axe
killer does kill his wife later on so i
think they're trying to like set him up
for that too but it's not like super
effective you know what i'm saying
because they're just there's so many
characters and like i said i forget what
all of them and sometimes it's so brief
or so subtle that i didn't even realize
until afterward that they were trying i
was like oh they're trying to make that
seem like that guy maybe this guy is the
killer maybe that guy's a killer you
know what i mean they're just like
introducing like all of these characters
just so they'd have more
suspects i guess but i will say that the
scenario that the movie is trying
hardest to sell
is that the killer is lillian's cousin
charlie
so lillian explains to gerald at one
point that when charlie was a kid
she was like pushing him on a swing and
she pushed him too hard and he fell off
and fractured his skull so this injury
apparently caused some brain damage and
charlie had to be institutionalized for
a while
um now she says he's recently gotten out
and lillian has deduced that charlie has
come back to town and is like taking
revenge against people who either had
some involvement in putting him in the
mental hospital in the first place or
people who worked there so i guess like
once he got out he's like yeah i'm gonna
kill all those [ __ ] um then
that's why when i said earlier like the
very first scene like with the woman
getting killed in the car wash and why
they linger on this like little red
cross sticker that she has they're like
oh it's a nurse you know what i mean so
it does kind of make sense later on
one thing that doesn't make sense though
is that a bunch of the victims like
including the beautician slash
prostitute uh the lady that was the
church choir director stuff like that no
no hint is really given that any of
those people were medical personnel or
had anything to do with the hospital
uh so there's that but lillian actually
kind of sort of like waves this away by
saying oh and by the way charlie is also
killing women that his father that his
father has the hots for i think i think
that's what she's getting at so they had
to have some kind of way because it
would be like be super suspicious if
like oh all these nurses or and doctors
are turning up dead then everybody be
like oh pattern but the fact it's like
all these random ass people and it's
like one of them was a nurse at the
beginning and then like the other ones
weren't anything to do with that so it's
like i said they were trying to make
everything like mysterious but they just
in a lot of ways they just kind of made
it like not coherent they're like not
make any sense you know what i mean it's
and i'm not saying it's a bad movie it's
actually like really fun i had a fun
time with it but it is like a little odd
and don't like get too wrapped up in the
story because it doesn't make a lot of
sense that's all i'm saying so along
those same lines it's like it's further
implied that gerald who just arrived in
town not too long before with no
explanation as i said so you're led
you're supposed to be believing that
gerald is actually charlie and that he's
the one that's the axe murderer and they
really lean into this a lot because
lillian actually even accidentally calls
him charlie at one point i think she's
even like he's even on a swing or some
[ __ ] like that and then later she
comments on the scar on the back of his
neck which um you know he says oh it's
from a motorcycle accident like all
sketchy and everything and so people
that are watching the movie are supposed
to think oh that was the scar that was
caused by falling off the swing and so
he's really charlie and he's the axe
murder but i will say that because i've
seen a lot of giallo movies and slasher
murder mysteries of this type i was
aware right from the jump that the
narrative that they were pushing so hard
uh that's never the solution to the
mystery it's always a misdirect and
indeed it was in this case um and when i
found out what the twist was i was
absolutely vindicated because i called
it
now as i surmised and this is spoiler
alert spoiler alert spoiler alert if you
do not want to know what the twist is
then
click off and go watch this movie and
then come back because i'm about to tell
you
so just as i predicted the killer
actually turns out to be
lillian
who did actually she was the one that
fell off a swing and got brain damage uh
as a kid and then she got
institutionalized
and basically had some murderous
revengey sort of impulses and spun those
off
into another personality named charlie
so she essentially like dissociated her
murderous impulses into another person
and now that narrative has become like
ingrained so she actually does think of
charlie as like another person and that
it's not her
um now i did actually like this twist
even though it was still fairly obvious
but
i will comment that whenever the axe
murder is shown during the kill scenes
it's very very clearly
a man i mean like this a big man like
this is i mean the the woman that's
playing lillian is like a small like
20 22 year old woman uh you know and
she's like i said she's quite petite uh
it's obviously not the same person
so uh so i'm actually not sure and maybe
i don't know
i'm actually not sure if the movie was
trying to imply that gerald was actually
the killer all along
but that he was trying to gaslight
lillian into thinking she was charlie
like that's a possibility too
but the scene at the very very end where
gerald actually gets shot by the police
and then i think like the useless you
know butthole sheriff hugs lillian and
says oh it's the nightmare's over there
won't be any more murders but then she
kind of like looks up and like smiles
maniacally like at the camera and then
they freeze frame and then the credits
run that would seem to imply otherwise
that would seem to imply that she was
the killer the whole time and that she
almost had kind of like a split
personality deal but the fact that they
clearly showed the axe murder a few
times and it was a man like i'm not
really sure like what they were getting
at with that but i don't know maybe it's
that i'm putting way more thought into
this than anyone else did which you know
that is obviously just like me because
that's something i would do so i've
thought about this like way more than
that is healthy uh clearly but yeah it's
i mean if you guys have any ideas let me
know so i mean all in all this is
actually a pretty enjoyable slasher if
you like slashers uh it has this quirky
almost like off-putting vibe but it
makes it kind of like interesting to
watch it's nothing to really write home
about as far as like there's nothing
that's all that like earth-shattering in
it but the axe kills are pretty decently
handled like i said they're not gory but
they're kind of like violent in the
sense that you actually get to see the
axe like going into people like that
like from a you know they don't cut away
or have insert shots or anything like
that
um you know and the special effects
particularly that corpse uh shot at the
near the beginning are actually pretty
good uh for this era the characters uh
gonna say are almost all unappealing
jerks except for lillian who's who's
lovely um and there's kind of way too
much time spent on meaningless subplots
and characters that are only like
crammed in there to have more red
herrings and like make the mystery more
mysterious or whatever but you know i
guess that's kind of par for the course
for kind of a low budget murder mystery
which is essentially what this is so i
can't really judge too harshly for that
so if you like slashers and you want to
see one that's kind of like more of the
same like it has a lot of the slasher
tropes but also has some like weird
eccentricity to it then it's definitely
worth checking out um i wouldn't go so
far as to call it a lost classic but if
you like slashers you should probably
get around to seeing it um the aero
release if that's the one that's on uh
2b i think right now it actually looks
really nice like the restoration is uh
is lovely and uh i think that the
blu-ray also has like a [ __ ] ton of
extras on it so if you're into that then
that's definitely something that you
might want to pick up but uh yeah so
that'll do it for this flickers of fear
and i will see you guys again on the
next one
bye